just one quick reminder before we get
started the last reminder that today
immediately following this session there
will be a special reception up on the
second floor there'll be food drinks
possibly cake uh and at 5 30 we're going
to be starting our award-winning first
run of the Tony Awards so uh make sure
to come there and sharpen your good Tony
stories because uh
well
she should be leaving washing
[Music]
are you gonna blush
for waste
all of you wait you'll see you'll all
see
people can take photos videos and send
them to me they'll really need to tell
you
welcome back to the last session of the
day which is another student session and
I'm happy to present Robert thanks all
right
um
I'm not gonna I'm gonna differentiate a
little bit from the other talks I'm not
going to talk about anything technical
um I'm not even really going to use the
board except maybe to draw one picture I
just want to tell some stories more or
less
um which I think I don't know the goal
is to embarrass Tony a little bit so
this is what I want to do so okay
um
so look at me is Tony's I'm one of
Tony's many grad students I joined
Toronto in January 2013 halfway through
the year
um
my getting into Toronto was funny for me
because I only applied to Toronto on a
really the story is really weird you
know the story actually
Nina invited Steve to Newfoundland to
give a talk and then I met I met him of
course when he talked and then I ended
up like just chatting with him at a
party at your house and then uh
oh
here is my idea also how you could solve
ta tribulation problem there is this
approach and this approach I already
thought about that one and that didn't
work but that's the one's mine
yeah it's true
you're making me blush
um
and yeah and then we talked for a while
and then eventually steam was like oh so
are you gonna go to you applying to grad
school and I was like yeah I'm yeah
probably I don't know I hadn't really
thought about it and he was like you
should probably replace Toronto so I was
like oh okay so I applied to Toronto
um and I just I only applied that year
because I wasn't planning on graduating
at that time and then uh so I only
applied to Toronto and then I got in and
I was like oh okay well now I have to
graduate like right now so that's why I
came and ended up coming in January as
opposed to September so I had to like
cram the rest of my program into one
thing but anyways yeah
um even though getting into Toronto was
a funny thing kind of a funny path it
was like the perfect fit for me
um there was really like I really felt
like no pressure to perform in some
sense like other than the pressure that
I was kind of putting on myself of which
I think I was putting a lot of pressure
on myself like many grad students do
um but there was never any profession to
perform particularly from from from
either Tony nor Steve
um like they all they ever really wanted
to do was like talk about science and I
always felt really free to like to work
on whatever problems I wanted to which
was like a really good fit and um
there's a couple of funny things I mean
there's a lot of funny stories that I
could tell one funny story that I'm
gonna that I'll tell is or do you
remember the time I don't know if I told
you this story actually so you asked me
once to substitute in for your for your
second year
like algorithms and data structures
class
did I tell you this story
no that was not that was definitely not
what happened so
so I went so I so I I showed up to class
it was like about maybe a month into
this it was maybe a month into the
semester so I I Tony was of course going
away to a conference or something and I
was around so I was like yeah I can
cover this class teaching DFS or
something so I walked into the class
um and I walked in and I walked in
really flustered like I walked in like
it's unbelievable I walked in and I came
in the board and I went up to the board
and I was like okay hello everybody my
name is Tony potassium
um
and I don't actually I didn't actually
know I was supposed to be teaching the
course this semester and so some lady
has just been coming in every day and
teaching this course the whole time
and I actually had them going like I did
this and then no one left and they all
slowly I remember focusing on one
student and I was just watching her
mouth just go
and then after like five minutes of
keeping this up I was like
okay I'm kidding right like I'm kidding
I'm my name's Robert I'm Tony's Grand
student and everybody was like oh look
it was like the whole room
so yeah so um
probably why I didn't tell you that
story
yeah it's funny because like I guess
none of them ever mentioned that to you
but anyways yeah so this is an idea of
of how relaxed the atmosphere at Toronto
was or at least how relaxed I tried to
make it
um but anyways like
um one thing I want I really want to
talk about is like
um talking about collaborating with Tony
as a grad student
um
like I said I kind of like to work on
everything like I really don't really
constrain myself in my liquid I like to
work on Lower bounds I love complexity
Theory but I mean I really don't
constrain myself the one sort of thing I
like to think about lots of things and
Tony's the exact same way like she likes
to think about almost everything right
and she's made all these fantastic
contributions in all these different
areas so you know for that reason I
think like it's a really good fit
whenever we would work together you know
I feel like
we would hop after we we very quickly we
would like work on a problem and then
get stuck and then be like oh maybe we
should think about something else and
then think about something else for a
couple of months and it was like I don't
know it was very fluid and I really
liked that kind of working and I like
that kind of like um I it always felt
like we were kind of on the same
wavelength in that sense so I really
appreciate that and that really gave me
the model for like how to collaborate I
think with other people and also my own
students who like now who I don't know I
we I think have a very casual
relationship we like to talk about lots
of things right stuff on I don't know
what do you think sure
yeah
anyways
Tony one of the things about working
with Tony there I'm sure that everybody
knows is that like
this is something that I really learned
from her I think is how everything is
completely intuitive for her like like
just complete intuition and she'll
describe the most like if you you could
open up some scary Yellow Book and you
know pick ethereum in it and you'll have
no idea what's going on in it and she'll
and then you're gonna go ask her and
she'll just be like oh yeah and then
she'll just give you this like super
stripped down concrete example that just
completely explains everything and like
it it like sometimes I feel like I don't
know like she's so good at math but like
she doesn't know the name of anything
so like like and I'll be like oh it's
like this and I'll say like a math thing
like oh yeah that's like a that's
like and she'll be like yeah and she'll
be like I don't know what you're talking
about I have a very vivid memory of a
meeting that we had where we I was
explaining some yeah Ultra product
construction because I thought it was
related to something and then we walked
out of the meeting we ran into someone
in the hall meeting with Steve and you
said the first thing that you said was
like oh my God I think Robert almost
killed me
but anyways but then yeah and like I
wasn't it wasn't super complicated math
like she wanted she understood exactly
everything that was going on it was just
that she understood it in her own
language right and that was something
that I really took away it's like like I
really probably the one of the biggest
lessons I learned during grad school was
like you really have to learn everything
in your own language and you cannot now
I I cannot listen to other people
explain things like I have to go away
and like figure it out myself and I feel
like that that was like a big lesson
that I really learned from Tony
um another thing is that like with Tony
said it was so casual that like I feel
like I I hope that other people have
this kind of relationship with their
advisor but
um
like like I like I feel like we have a
lot of inside jokes and so I'm gonna
draw a picture and I'm gonna see if you
oh no see if you remember it
you remember this
but that is the tattoo
no that's what it was well there was
multiple I guess
but yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so we have this one yeah right so guys
and this is exactly my point like this
is the level of relationship that would
that like we had right
um when we were do you remember the
status you should remember this picture
too
yeah we were working on this paper that
actually led to both the stabbing planes
paper and the random cnf's paper
um with Dennis me Tony and Noah and we
kept making the same mistake in some
upper bound argument over and over and
over and over again for like six months
I think
one thing different every single time
and then eventually we were just like oh
my God we're just gonna have to tattoo
this on our body like it's the only way
that we're gonna remember it and then
eventually we just started calling that
problem the tattoo and then so like I
wouldn't check back and checked through
my emails and I have a whole bunch of
emails just like titled tattoo like it's
like no this is the tattoo this is a
tattoo and then I was thinking
ironically I did just get a tattoo but I
didn't get the tattoo so it's yeah
anyways so I don't know
they still cut space I still don't
understand that's true I've got lots of
body left
um okay let's see
um
so those are the positive things without
collaborating with Tony so
uh the negative thing okay not negative
things there's very little negative
things about uh collaborating with Tony
I don't I don't think but like there are
I'm sure we all know that Tony has
certain habits like she's not terribly
good with computers
um and in particular another thing
that's really funny is that like she has
this weird thing that happened
usually 7 several times a meeting like
what will happen is oh sorry one second
I'm sorry yeah sorry yeah no I'm giving
a talk right now yeah can I call you
back yeah okay
yeah so what's really annoying is that
like several times a meeting
her phone will ring and she'll have a
conversation that's exactly four
sentences I'm in a meeting can I call
you who is calling you all the time
I don't believe it
you know how many hours
yeah
um the other thing when it comes the
other thing I know I will have a lot
more stories about Tony but Tony's
computers I think but like um
another thing was like I think for like
like a full two-year period
in order to compile a latex file you
would email it to me so that I could
compile them
don't remember this because latex was
broken on your computer for like two
years
I remember this
I might just give you to my son
the other thing that you do all the time
is like she would be like I think she
would you of course you have these big
long you know discussions where you're
discussing theorems improving things and
all this fun stuff and then eventually
like a week will pass and you'll get
Izzy or something and you'll forget to
talk and then uh you'll get an email
from her in the same email chain being
like oh uh I think we talked about this
but I can't find the email can you like
send it to me and it would be in the
same email too like I would just scroll
up like four emails and like copy it and
send it
which actually I think I've done to you
so oh yeah so this is a bad habit that
I'm thinking of
um
okay
um all right so five minutes left wow I
can't believe I actually managed to film
this okay so
um I guess I want to talk now a little
about maybe like a little bit more
serious well not serious but yeah so
when I when I finished my PhD
um I think probably like many people
um I felt like I had kind of lost
Direction a little bit
um like I kind of finished my thesis and
I like submitted it and I had these
postdocs lined up
um which were good post talks right like
I came to Simon's and then I had the
joint postdoc at IIs and Rutgers so I
was like really happy in that sense I
was excited to do it but at the same
time like I also felt like I kind of
lost Direction like I'd
um like I just kind of lost motivation
to work for for a bit and I think this
is probably pretty common but it
actually affected me I don't I didn't we
never really talked about this
explicitly I don't think although maybe
you sensed something but like um
uh I never really talked about this
review or really really with many people
other than really close friends and I
actually I actually almost left I was
seriously considering leaving Academia
to the point where I actually almost
where I actually almost basically had a
job lined up a friend of mine had had a
startup it was like he was doing really
cool stuff not not programming but like
some solar panel sustainability thing
and he was like basically look invited
me to be like person number three and I
was like oh wow okay that sounds really
cool actually and I was feeling kind of
weird about it and so I seriously did
consider it and so then I but then uh so
I was kind of balancing these things in
my head
um and I think what happened to me is
that like maybe this happened to a lot
of people too is that I went to grad
school kind of that like a because I
love the science but also B because I
kind of wanted to prove to myself that I
could do it you know what I mean
and then when I proved to myself that I
could do it like some of that motivation
just kind of left I think right and then
it was like okay well now all the
motivation had to come from somewhere
else and it took me a couple years to
kind of reconfigure my motivations for
that to make sense right
um so I don't know if you said something
or not but but there's this very Vivid I
have a for me it's a very important
thing that happened which was when we
were at lower bounds here in 2018 we
went to Stanford that one day yeah yeah
and that day was like super important to
me
and uh yeah like well I I didn't want to
cry and I'm gonna cry oh my God I'm so
sorry
um yeah that day was actually like super
important to me like um
if it wasn't for that I don't think it
would have continued
yeah so um to this day I mean like
um
we're still collaborating and like I
still have like a weekly meeting in my
calendar every week to meet with Tony
even though we skip most of them
because one of us are busy but it's
still there so we still meet every week
on Zoom
and I wouldn't have it any other way
personally so I just want to thank you
for all the support I want to thank you
for being my favorite collaborator
oh my God
most of all I want to thank you for
teaching me how to be a scientist
all right I love you Tony
can I ask a question Robert yeah sure
how many academic grandkids does Tony
have thanks to you okay well I mean
they're not official yet
yeah I have three students right now
and just hired a fourth
I'll look alike
thanks thanks Robert are there any other
questions
you're getting so it's a bludgeoned
there is you know in Saturday Night Live
Mike Myers used to say you know I've
been a bunch of Talk Amongst yourselves
you know while you recomposes and that
reminds me that Tony uh was Rosanna
Danna
you know Rosanna Danna was never better
than you were
so for those who remember that there was
a star performance unfortunately we
didn't video things then
any other questions
speaking of technological difficulties
uh I had a grad student contemporary
Alan Skelly who alleged that in order to
search Google Tony would go to Yahoo and
type in Google
that's right
I remember that I
Googled it anyways it's nice and
circular but I don't think
I remember during
during an undergrad you were telling me
that sometimes you're purposely not
learning new technology because you need
space in your brainful you know
important things
and that was quite a normal idea to an
undergrad me at the time and I keep
thinking about it all the time since
then
hey uh can you hear me oh Josh yeah yeah
I just wanted so Robert I think uh your
story about the Tony emailing you stuff
to latex actually happened around the
the time when uh when I was a postdoc
there and I think
um Tony and my I think actually Tony
might have been sparing you because
um at the time I was using Dropbox for
our our ipf paper and I think that was
like the first time Tony had ever used
Dropbox and and at one point
she had actually she like didn't
understand that Dropbox was like synced
across everyone's good and so she she
actually deleted our Fox paper
um
and and luckily I had a backup but uh I
I think maybe that experience might have
scared her and she said no I'm just
going to email Robert the thing instead
of have him compile it and I'm not gonna
listen yeah
the thing about getting rid of
everything
any other comments
false rivers or anything
okay thanks again Robert
our next talk I think is by sayak
chakravarti I'm not sure whether it's an
online it's an in-person great
thank you
so hey thanks hello
I am a first year PhD student under Tony
and I am at Columbia advised by Josh and
Tony both of them are amazing students
amazing advisors
sorry about that so both of them are
amazing advisors but since it's Tony's
birthday I'm going to talk about how
wonderful she is
and how she has like taught me a lot
about research in the last two semesters
so yeah very happy Birthday Tony
and
so working with her is always been
really inspiring she has been giving a
lot of ideas and
it's like she has an amazing intuition
about problems and as Robert talked
about she has just her own way of
thinking about problems and like
providing directions which like she has
suggested us papers which she hadn't
read but she knew the idea and she knew
how to use it even though it was never
obvious at the first look how to like
have some applications in some other
problems which we later came up with
so she was always inspiring and
supportive in that day and she also like
she gave me the freedom to explore every
other problem I wanted to like I was
interested in computational algebra
since 500 and even though like she
doesn't work too much on that she gave
us a lot of ideas and avenues to explore
which I'll come to again
and
moving on I'll make it a bit more
technical now
so one of the things I'm interested in
is computation algebra and one Central
problem in that is solving a system of
polynomial equations
it's like you have give you are given a
set of polynomials M polynomials in N
variables of degree Atmos d and you and
it can be over any field or any ring and
you want to find a common root of that
and for the case of Simplicity we might
assume that this field is just FP where
you have the polynomials mod P
and this is an NP complete problem
because like it's an NP because you if
you have a root you can verify if that
is a solution or not
and you can arithmetize set to a system
of polynomials
and there is different settings of this
problem so the input size is the number
of monomials times the size of any size
of each monomial and for p equal to
constant and D being constant Q three
side reduces to
and then variate polynomial system
and
there have been some Works where
there is this 1999 work where they can
solve a system of polynomials Over N
variables having time complexity
polynomial in D to the power c n and log
P where CN is a pretty large quantity
so Tony and I had some discussions on
how to improve this and
well she as I said she was already
always very insightful and give
motivations and great insights into
other avenues and she did
like give a give an intuition for
reducing this the usual techniques of
doing this is reducing all these
polynomials to a single polynomial and
then solving for roots
so she gave an idea and that was a
really nice one but turns out that it
was already present in this clean idea
by Ryan Williams who might be here and
others
where the solve it better than Brute
Force having a
factor of P to the power Epsilon n
better than the brute force and this
also works in several settings but I
will not go into the details of that
now
moving on from modulo primes to modulo
Composites it's like
this ring Z by P to the power k z means
you are working modulo P to the power k
and now this is a more difficult problem
than working what P because
this weird things happen in this case
so every element of pot p23 K can be
written as this sequence a0 plus A1 P up
to a k minus one p two zero K minus one
where each of the AIS are from 0 to P
minus 1
and
why is this weird because if for example
if we consider this polynomial x square
plus p x mod P Square there are P minus
P many roots of a polynomial of degree d
for degree two
for each of the I from 0 to 3 minus 1 it
will give you a root which is like kind
of surprising that there are so many
roots of
one low degree polynomial
so an interesting question is how to
find this modular higher powers of P
and this one term called unique
factorization domain which since it is
not I'll not go into the details but
the the this property not being
satisfied makes these problems really
difficult to entertain difficult to
solve
now
we have when we are solving some
polynomials modular Composites we will
have roots of this form where each of
the AIS are not P from 0 to P minus 1.
so a natural idea is to reduce this
problem of solving mod P to the power K
to solving several problems module of P
which is like solving mod P is
relatively more easy
so we reduce each of the AIS to over FP
and in order to find the first
coordinate a0 it's easy to see that we
can just consider F mod P and then find
the root over modulo P to find a0 but
now moving on to find A1
we can
modify this polynomial F into a new
polynomial which is called f of a plus p
x where a a should be the first
coordinate a zero
and if you do that you can introduce see
that if this has root A1 then the entire
root would be a0 plus P A1
so if we reduce out the higher powers of
P this will exactly reduce the system to
FP again
now
this technique of finding a0 and then
finding the next coordinator of A1 is
also called lifting of roots which is
like not exactly same as the lifting of
proof complexity
but
so let's consider another example of one
P Square notice that x cubed minus x
square plus P has two Roots mod P which
are 0 and 1.
so we first find the first coordinate
which is which can be either 0 or 1 and
then we slowly move up to higher powers
now if we first consider the root zero
lifting would give us the polynomial
1 by P times F of 0 plus p x which is
this polynomial and you can see that mod
P this has no root which means that the
root zero does not lift to mod P Square
whereas if you consider the other root
one then you will see that it gives
another polynomial which does give a
root for P Square so the natural
question is is that which root should we
choose
some so it's not just not P Square but
for higher mod P to zero K we don't know
which route we should select which will
lift all the way it might so happen that
you select some root which lifts to say
k minus 2 and then stops lifting to K
minus 1.
so we want some technique to ensure that
it lifts all the way
so there is this celebrated result by
Hansen which lifts roots and factors to
any power of K any value of K but it's
it only works in special cases
building on this there there was this
2013 result which gives roots of
univariates mod P to zero k and they can
find exactly the roots but cannot find
the factors which Hensel lifting can
so
we noticed that
always univariate lifting difficult from
multivariates
in order to do that we kind of employ
the same idea
that
we first consider the first coordinate a
bar a bar can now be seen as a vector in
FP to the power n it has n coordinates
and it only consists of the roots modulo
p and then you will slowly move on to
finding Roots modulo P Square
and in this way you will reduce this
problem again to finding
Solutions of a polynomial mod P
but it will
it and after that you will use the usual
technique of solving our FP to find
roots
but the problem in this case again is
that the time complexity becomes very
bad that it becomes polynomial in D to
the power C and C and K where C and K is
quite large
so
so it will be really nice to improve
this this exponent so that we can more
efficiently find roots and factors of
polynomials mod P to the power k and so
that we can generalize hand cells
lifting
that is
this only works when n times K is
constant but if we could do something
better then we could move up to higher k
and
so this naturally gives rise to some
open problems which are like when p is
large can we solve the system in D to
the power n to the power C where C does
not depend on n
and we can assume that P is quite large
or we could Ryan Williams ask this
question of
whether we can improve the Epsilon in P
to the power 1 minus Epsilon times n
where Epsilon actually has some
dependence on the degree and the prime
so if that could be improved that would
be really nice too
and also for solving mod P to the power
K can we do this better for some large p
and large K because the previous
technique was only restricted to very
small constant case
and factoring unit variates and
generalizing handsets lifting
so this is the kind of problems I am
currently interested in I am also
exploring a bit of more other other
problems with Tony on communication
complexity and she has been really
helpful so far and she has like she's
advised me in a wonderful way for the
last two semesters
and I am looking forward to several more
and thank you for everything and happy
birthday
[Applause]
I decided any questions
a minor in in the audience
thanks again thanks
[Applause]
I think we have one more speaker in the
session
and that's going to be Noah Fleming just
give him a minute to set up
okay
foreign
[Laughter]
but I just kind of wanted to give like a
fun little retrospective of my PhD now
that it's done and I can I can look back
at this and laugh
[Laughter]
um and I guess the the sort of takeaway
from this uh is that it's good to work
on hard problems uh you may not always
solve them but you might solve something
else that's also interesting
and make you may cry a lot
[Laughter]
um okay
I can do it this way okay
um so I'm going to start with my
undergrad and kind of how I met Tony
um so one day I went to Antonia's office
and I'd heard about this thing called
complexity Theory
do you really know much about it I
probably knew a lot less than she
thought I knew because I basically just
read the Wikipedia article and I thought
like sounds cool maybe maybe I should do
something of this
uh and so antonina knew I had done like
a math undergrad it was just like you
might like proof complexity so it's like
I guess I like proof complexity
um and so the first paper I read was
this paper
um by Tony and others and uh turns out
this is like a was a very influential
paper to me I I didn't really realize
that until like today so here's two
things that it mentions in it
well okay I scored a new one but like
yeah okay the first thing is it's not
known okay it might be too small but
it's not known uh what the shortest
proofs of The Cutting plane uh the
shortest cutting planes proofs of the uh
odd charge graph formulas are or the
site and formulas or random formulas
okay
um so yeah one open problem site and
lower bounds the second one is that it
talks about this uh so in this paper
they prove lower bounds on cutting
planes proofs uh with small coefficients
so these click color formulas and some
other ones but they also prove lower
bounds on a sort of stronger proof
system which does this
um they call it cutting planes with
deduction and engineer and I looked at
this for a little bit um
but it is basically
um you kind of augment cutting planes
with a pre-processing step first you can
take your unsatisfiable CNF formula and
you're allowed to make this binary tree
where you branch on threshold formulas
you branch on whether they're true or
false and then at each Leaf of this
binary balanced binary tree it's
important that it's balanced
um you have little cutting planes
reputations of the formulas together
with everything along the path
this is inspiration for something else
um yeah okay so first question uh that
we decide to look at is like yeah it's
sight and hard for cutting plans the
second one is like what can we say about
like
these cutting planes proofs with
deduction uh in the case of the trees
are unbalanced maybe maybe what if we
just restrict from threshold formulas to
a little integer linear inequalities
um okay so I was already thinking about
this in undergrad uh okay so I should
Define what Satan is you probably all
know but you're given graph maybe
there's an odd number of vertices and
you know variables for the the edges and
it asserts that there's a way to like uh
edges like say this Edge is in the graph
uh such that every vertex has an odd
number of adjacent edges uh of course
since the number of vertices is odd this
is unsatisfiable
and then also all the fine cutting
points but not not so fun
um yeah see in cutting plans you prove
that a polytope has no integer points
it's the same as refuting and
unsatisfiable C enough formula just by
encoding uh you have this the tall
gomori cut rule you can take a linear
inequality which is valid for the
polytopes that means it lies outside the
polytope
um and just let's say that
coefficients or integral and you can
round it up and this what this does is
it shaves off some non-integer points of
the polytote but preserves image reports
so cutting plates proof is just a
sequence of polytopes starting with your
initial one and deriving the empty
polyte open because you preserved
integer points
um there's no there could have been no
foreign
and then the other thing was yeah the
other question was like what about these
cutting planes with deduction where you
branch on linear inequalities maybe have
some uh I don't excuse me
quickly drawn picture of what it looks
like yeah you branches of linear integer
linear inequalities and there's little
cutting Point groups as well
okay uh so I worked with antonita for a
while at Noosa lab uh and then Cody came
for a visit and we hung out for a bit
and chatted about cutting planes and I'm
sure like half of it went over my head
but I enjoyed what I heard
um and so I emailed her and here is the
first email I can find from Tony I'm
sure there were other ones but they were
sent to uh
from an email address they don't have
access to anymore anyway so I I got this
like Grant from the Canadian government
to go down for a summary to Toronto uh
and this was one instance of the uh
Infamous Newfoundland to Toronto
pipeline if there's been three people
now that have come from antonina to uh
to U of T
um Robert is one of them uh yeah okay so
then we worked for a summer on a seems
to be a rite of passage
um
at least I know Robert's gone through
this I think you went through this Tony
which is reading a paper uh which just
takes months and months and months to
understand this was this lifting theorem
for um uh shrawley Adams proves to
Extended formulations I think I finally
understand it now so if you want to chat
we can I can explain it
uh okay we chatted a bit about sighting
um yeah and we noticed that uh
sorry to do this uh but you can
officially prove site and by branching
on these inequalities this will come up
later uh the high ideas you take the
graph you do like a balanced cut in the
graph and then you ask about the number
of edges that are crossing the cut and
then you recurse on the side that uh as
a violation
the easy upper band
um and sort of around this time also uh
I think we chatted with Russell a little
bit about this cutting planes with
deduction he just suggested okay rather
than doing these cutting points proofs
it believes let's throw that out and
let's just do the branching uh so we
thought this was like probably a weak
proof system
um
uh
okay and so unfortunately after working
on this for quite a while the best name
we could come up with for it was
stabbing planes
um
okay so stabbing planes yeah you've
probably seen it I should just Define
these things
um it's uh yeah again you start with a
polytope or a system of in manager
linear inequalities and it's a binary
tree where each internal node is uh it
has two outgoing edges they query
whether an integer linear inequality is
true or false Branch or whether ax grade
equal to b or X less than or equal to b
1 4.
um and your goal is to derive the empty
polytope at each of the leaves because
any integer Point sat is going to
survive one of these two inequalities
you're not going to if there were
satisfying us integer assignments to the
polytope
uh then uh one of the leaves wouldn't
get them empty
so here's a little picture
there's there's the little seven points
proof and what happens at each step is
you
you branch on uh
um
range of this inequality and you rule
out the the fractional points in between
okay uh so uh at the end of my summer
with Tony uh she was really nice and sat
down with me and like
um suggested all these places I should
go like apply for a PhD uh and of course
a good student I was I uh ignored her
and just applied T of T so glad I got in
um but uh yeah I don't know it was a
really lovely place to be everybody was
really welcoming uh really friendly one
thing that like really shocked me the
first time I was there is that people
were like treating me as an equal which
I don't know was really weird because I
was an undergrad like why are you asking
me what I think I don't know anything
that's still true
um okay so PhD I worked on on many
things some related to complexity Theory
some not
es you're about to cut that polytoke
with the polytope is made of cheese and
also I'm about to cut it with some
cheese
found this well looking for another
picture on my yeah hard drive
uh yeah okay so Satan and stabbing
plants were still a main focus
um during this time with Robert and
Dennis uh
and we made a little bit of progress
um so we showed lower bounds than the
following proof system which is the call
cutting planes star star hotel star
um uh
um and these proofs have coefficients of
little oven and I think I'm lying here
actually I think there's a couple of
caveats first caveat but I remember is I
think the coefficients have to all be
positive or something like that or maybe
all oriented in the same way and the
second one is I think the proof may have
a bug
um anyway so this is going to be a theme
okay and then so some real progress so
this this is when you know your PhD is
going well your supervisor breaks her
ankle I'm sorry Tony so this Mythic
Toady was at home like basically
homebound
um and really really bored
uh so here's an example here's an email
from two in the morning
this is just a segment of it I looked at
the emails like several patients um and
at that time we had been thinking about
a lot of different things kind of uh
we've been reading these old cry check
papers about
um these PLS games
herself
[Laughter]
also also another funny thing is what I
was going back through my emails the
number of emails that are called more of
the same or same
[Laughter]
actually
if you go back here and if you zoom in
on there I have a printed out email from
Tony that says same on it yeah
thank you
[Laughter]
just forget which student it is it's
just it'll eventually go through
um
yeah okay so Tony broke her ankle uh and
we were okay weird
um yeah so we were we were thinking
about this paper by cry check talks
about his PLS games I think also it's
paper as prop and also reading some
stuff by Mika and I think Tony
um that talk about this monotone
they kind of pieced it together is it uh
that this sort of more General
interpolation thing where you can
actually take any CNF formula and turn
it into a
um
cutting Point cutting points proof of
any CNF formula turn it into a monotone
Circuit of a containing some Associated
partial functions
um okay and we use this to show that
random CNF formulas are hard for
references
email from uh and so that natural
question I think this is the first thing
we tried was like can we apply this to
sighting like can we get this
um so unfortunately Satan has small
monotone circuits this is why this
problem we thought okay this problem is
really hard this is makes it a better
problem to attack everybody thinks it
starts so
um I I should say caveat here I don't
think Tony really pushed me to work on
this from I think she knew how hard it
was and I just really wanted to work on
it
uh okay so we had no idea how to
approach it and I think didn't work
super hard on it worked out on a bunch
of other things at this point and um
Tony and I worked on other things
um
so as uh as a lot of you know Tony has
famously very broad research interests
but what some of you might not know is
that Tony and I actually published an
academic book on sword fighting uh so if
you
um excuse me I'm gonna show you the book
uh in a second to make sure that
they pulled up
I just play music or it might not I
don't know it's better that it does
okay
[Music]
budget candidates
so I didn't do this I didn't make this
this arrived at my house
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's a very proud owner of a book by
myself and Tony on legacies of the sword
also this great is a Time versus skill
graph is incredible
yeah so probably one of my favorite
things that's ever happened to me
[Music]
um
okay and then so we finally solved it
sorry for everybody involved
um I I dredged this up from somewhere
this is the old
attempt
um turns out that we had made an
assumption which I think was even in the
old old old the even the the result I
mentioned before for the linear
coefficients might have been in there as
well so it didn't work yes there was a
problem with this
which was that there are cutting plants
proofs of sight and uh
so
I'm going to redeem myself I'm going to
convince you that it's not my fault of
these proofs
okay so what what does uh what does this
result do
um what they do is they take actually
these stabbing planes proofs that I
mentioned at the start where you do this
like polytope you pick the graph you
partition in half and you query how many
and then they translate it into cutting
planes using this really weird way
um and we kind of generalized this and
showed that actually
um stabbing plans if the coefficients
are not too large is equal to cutting
points so you can translate it that way
um yeah so we we're uh but one one thing
about this is that it converts like to
be shallow stabbing points groups now
the the proofs of the setting formula I
think I say this actually
okay yeah
remember it's shallow proofs into very
very deep proofs
um
so the the proofs of the site and
formulas that we gave
uh in southern plans had
quasi uh closet polynomial size and poly
logarithmic depth uh but the the size
and the depth of the resulting cutting
planes proofs are both quasi-polynomials
so what does this look like okay so I
didn't actually say what
how you can think of cutting plane steps
but like just like how in resolution you
have a dag and you derive things you can
think about cutting planes in the same
way and every proof has a okay say this
probably yeah uh every proof has a
refutation of
sorry every formula has a reputation of
linear depth in cutting planes but these
proofs here have
quasi-polynomial depth which is really
strange they just look like one big long
weird path and the reason I said I'm
going to redeem myself is this is a
really weird thing to find like how
would you ever think of doing whatever
is going on here
um okay
so a conjecture we made in sort of a
newer paper is that any sub-exponential
size cutting planes proof
um of the site and formulas actually has
to have this poly logarithmic depth
um
Satan has exponential size cutting
points groups with linear depth
um and so what we're asking is for a
super critical trade-off if you
strip the size uh then the depth goes
like Way Beyond the worst case
not many examples of these in the
literature some examples are there's a
trade-off between resolution size and
space and most of these trade-offs are
for resolution
um there's a trade-off between tree-like
resolution size and depth
uh and recently we've proved a trade-off
between cutting planes size and depth
but it really does not hold per second
um it needs a totally different
technique
uh okay and and so why why is this
conjecture interesting
I mean that these cutting place groups
are very difficult to find they're very
long and skinny
um
so I think that's everything I wanted to
say
so this is the only picture I could find
of me and Tony I'm amazed we don't have
any other pictures together but it it
goes back to 2016 at BAM which is Avi
baby me and baby Robert
happy birthday
[Applause]
thank you yeah any questions
just to say that probably the most
important for complexity series things
that I learned from Tony is exactly the
Newfoundland Toronto pipeline
biggest contribution to the field is
connecting you and Robert to Tonya
that's kind of obvious
[Laughter]
when you do it for me when I was an
undergrad she introduced me to Steve so
this year turned that's what I learned
communities
well we're just asking for anything
super like a super critical trade-off so
really anything right but you could ask
for something uh weaker which is just a
super fundamental uh yeah that would
also be great
so but somehow it seems like since
there's no exponential Urban possible
you seems to not be interested in this
yeah yeah I mean it's a weird place to
stop
um
any other questions
those legacies of the sword mention
stabbing planes I wish but the names are
like uncannily similar
theme you know you've done a word search
on those stabbing you know oh I should I
need to get a PDF of that thing
I'm sorry what's the book story oh the
book story it was oh so I didn't fully
tell it but I we like wrote this survey
on some of squares turned into a book
because it got really long
um and then it was with these but now
Publishers we said it there they gave us
they like sent us the first copies of
the book and I it's like oh this is kind
of fun I got my own little book open it
up and like open the first page and it
just says legacies of the sword
and I it's like very out of body like
surreal experience
so but it's not even published by the
same like company like it is not now
published did you ever get it yeah yeah
unfortunately not extra copies
on that
I wonder if they got a copy of my book
s
very very good let's go outside
okay let's thank Noah again thank you
[Applause]
so before everybody leaves the internet
just made a suggestion which is uh